اصبحت موجات الحر اكثر شيوعا منذ عصر ما
قبل الصناعه لكن عام 2022 كان بمثابه صدمه
للجميع ففي النصف الشمالي من الكره
الارضيه اجتاحت اوروبا موجه حر غير مسبوقه
حطمت الرقم القياسي وتسببت في حاله جفاف
في انحاء متفرقه من القاره خاصه في اواخر
الصيف يرجع العلماء ارتفاع درجات الحراره
والجفاف الى تغير المناخ والذي ادى الى
زياده عدد حرائق الغابات في غرب الولايات
المتحده خاصه في ولايه كاليفورنيا وهي
التي شهدت في السنوات الخمس الماضيه اكبر
الحرائق واكثرها تدميرا وفي غرب ووسط
افريقيا اثر هطل الامطار والفيضانات
المدمره على خمسه ملايين شخص هذا العام في
19 دوله وفقا لتقرير حديث لبرنامج الغذاء
العالمي سجلت نيجيريا 600 حاله وفاه على
الاقل بينما تقول السلطات في النيجر
المجاوره ان مئه واثنين 192 شخصا على
الاقل لقوا حتفهم هناك نتيجه العواصف سواء
بسبب انهيار منازلهم او الغرق في مياه
الفيضانات
حلت الكارثه على اكثر من مليون
وثلاثمائه الف شخص وفقا للارقام الحكوميه
وتسببت في نزوحهم وتعد فيضانات نيجيريا
عام 2022
الاسوء منذ اكثر من عقد عام 2022 جاء الى
باكستان
بويبال فيضانات مدمره وحراره شديده وفي
اغسطس اب كان الثلث البلاد تحت الماء
اضرار مسه اكثر من ثلاثه وثلاثين مليون
شخص في الدوله التي يبلغ عدد سكانها 220
مليون نسمه ومن المرجح ان تصبح هذه
الفيضانات اكثر شيوعا مع ارتفاع الحراره
العالميه ترتفع درجه حراره القطب الشمالي
اسرع بمرتين من بقيه العالم يقول الخبراء
انه في بعض المواسم ارتفعت درجه حرارته
ثلاث مرات اسرع من بقيه العالم
حقائق وارقام جعلت العلماء يتساءلون عما
اذا كانت بعض المناطق في العالم ستبقى
صالحه للعيش في غضون 50 او 100 عام